so I was finally depressed enough in my
life that I watched Black Adam a year
after it came out usually these not so
good comic book movies are on a delay
for me and I watched them like the
entertainment equivalent of stuffing
your face with ice cream after being
emotionally crushed and speaking of
crushed emotions Henry suited up one
last time as Superman for this
post-credits scene only for it to not
quite pan out sure there was an
embarrassing PS2 FMV appearance in the
flash but the Black Adam scene was
designed to tease a knock down drag out
battle between soups and Adam for a
sequel because Dane forgot whose villain
he was supposed to be as someone who
liked Henry as Superman it was sad to
see it end on a false hope like that but
it got me thinking this happens to a lot
of actors you get suited up for your big
teaser scene prep to take on a big comic
book role in a yet to be produced Sequel
and then behind the scenes troubles or
box office disappointment leaves the
whole scene of funny little Cliff note
on a fan Wiki somewhere so with the help
of a guy who just had to watch a bunch
of these scenes back to back for his
dceu timeline project the Watchtower
database is James strecker and I want to
take you down the list of all the end of
movie teases that never went anywhere
and rate them on a scale of man I wish
that happened to thank God that never
happened but while you're waiting for
that teaser of an intro to pay off how
ironic let's take a minute and teleport
to Talaria where the events of today's
sponsor raid Shadow Legends take place
raid Shadow Legends is the huge hit
among mobile games but it's also
available on PC as well so you don't
have to limit yourself the game is
allowing you to choose the pace of it
play casually and enjoy the high quality
Graphics or go deep dive in and compete
with others on PVP Arena in raid you
also have more than 700 unique Champions
to use and a lot of different strategies
which will help you to complete endless
challenges the game can offer bosses
dungeons Doom Tower and accomplishing
tutorials for you to master your skills
do you want a free legendary champion
silly question of course you do
especially when they're as cool as this
check out Sun Wukong raid's take on the
mischievous Monkey King coming as a free
legendary champion all you've got to do
is log into raid on seven different days
between August 22nd and October 23rd to
get your hands on this awesome champion
no heroic Journey to the West is
required just log in and that's it
with all this exciting stuff and more
coming to raid if you haven't started
playing yet then what are you waiting
for new players use my link or scan the
QR code right here and get a free
starter pack with this cool in-game loot
just hit my link in the description pass
the tutorial and see you on the
battlefield each accomplished tutorial
helps me to boost the content quality
for you to enjoy it more now back to the
video I did indeed have to suffer
through I mean watch a ton of these
recently for our dceu timeline video
over on the Watchtower database Channel
which you should absolutely watch
because it's basically a movie itself we
regularly do DC Animated Universe videos
over there so go check us out if you
haven't before anyway there are so many
of these superhero films that end with
some kind of hilarious setup for a
future sequel that we just know we're
never gonna get and we're about to spoil
a bunch of them sometimes it's an oh
thank God because I do not want to see
that other times it's a why why please
come on Delio and for me our first entry
falls into the latter category the
latigory you might say you shouldn't but
you might I saw a Black Adam in theaters
opening weekend but like any person who
gets on the internet for two seconds
these days I have had already had the
post-credits scene spoiled for me but it
didn't matter because seeing it is a
whole nother animal Henry Cavill was
back as Superman For The First Time in
Forever Superman would show up from time
to time in DC EU projects but always
headless or seen only from behind or in
silhouette it was never Henry it was
always random stunt double number four
sorry if you're a random stunt double
number four you did a fantastic job
honey but having Henry actually back in
the costume was beautiful I wasn't the
biggest fan of Man of Steel nor Batman v
Superman and certainly nor Justice
League the first one the bad one but all
the behind the scenes nonsense that went
on always made me feel bad for our
favorite mustachioed Englishman he
deserved better so seeing him pop up in
the end of Black Adam even uttering the
phrase it's been a while made me whisper
[__] yes with the biggest smile ever on
my face he was back he even announced it
public he and The Rock told the whole
world they were listening to the fans
and finally souped Henry back up I
wanted to make it official that I am
back as Superman
and the image you see on this post and
what you saw in Black Adam are just a
very small taste and then well the this
wound is pretty fresh you probably know
what happened basically LOL JK the
entire movie universe is being rebooted
the DC film slate is now Under New
Management new Henry Cavill list
management now I feel even worse for the
guy we'll never get a follow-up to this
we should talk moment and I hate that I
really do but life goes on I suppose the
new Superman movie I'm sure will still
kick ass and at least Black Adam
squeaked by with a better box office
performance than this one's a special
case of two post-credits scenes that
alternate depending on which version the
movie you're watching in a way these
sort of both came to fruition just not
the way they were teasing Wolverine
didn't end up in Japan for an adventure
before his time in the X-Men it wound up
happening much later after most of them
were killed off in their first attempt
at a dark Phoenix Saga meanwhile
Deadpool would eventually get his own
solo film that completely ignores the
existence of this one most of the time
and only acknowledges it to mock the
very notion of Baraka pool and his lack
of speech and his
confusingly paradoxically elbow bendy
what's going on there honestly even
though I was a big Deadpool fan as a kid
I wasn't totally heartbroken by this at
the time because my little nine-year-old
imagination ran in circles trying to
figure out how this could still end up
being the real deal maybe Wade's new
healing Factor went into overdrive after
this incident forced all the adamantium
out of his body including the elbow
joint blocking swords leaving his skin
horribly scarred all over maybe it's the
only superpower that stuck with him
maybe all the computerized garbage in
his brain left him a little loopy and
out of touch with reality it wasn't
completely unworkable but maybe it was
best for them to just skip all that
explanation entirely so he could just
get a perfectly Standalone movie that's
not reliant on some schlock put together
during a writer's strike
now on to the new movie with Wolverine
and Deadpool put together during a
writer's strike oh dear whatever will we
do without Ryan Reynolds ad-lib format
of calling someone a blank blanking
blank Ryan Reynolds you say what a
kawinky dink I was just gonna talk about
him well not him specifically but his
other superhero movie that everyone
loves to hate this was the first time
the character of Green Lantern got a
movie and Warner Brothers was so
confident in Reynolds and the movie that
they went ahead and commissioned sequel
scripts while Green Lantern was still in
the filming process that's one way to do
it because of this sequel bait must be
present and so we got this arguably
cooler than the rest of the movie
post-credits scene where Mark Strong's
Sinestro receives a yellow power ring
and a Yellow Lantern uniform the
beginnings of a Sinestro core I
personally am fascinated with the
Lantern color spectrum Mythos and all
the Techno Babble that surrounds it so
seeing shoddy screenshots of this
surface online months before the actual
movie had me hyped then I finally
watched Green Lantern two years later on
a laptop in a school classroom not
during actual school I was on Drum Corps
tour if you don't know what I mean then
it's too much to explain right now and
well yeah this isn't a very good movie
but this scene still rocks it's very
much too bad that the entire world
agreed with me and we never got more
Green Lantern movies at least at the
time of making this video that would
continue this yellow ring setup but at
least Mark Strong got another shot at
playing a high-profile DC villain ah
damn it I think that's the one I gotta
talk about next I have a fondness for
the frustrating time in comic book movie
history where Sony's plans for a shared
Marvel Universe within the bounds of
Spider-Man where this staunch insistence
that audiences were dying for a Sinister
Six movie no matter how underdeveloped
and rushed the team members may be don't
give everyone origin stories make them
all just various Oz Court projects to
strip away anything unique about them as
they Gear Up in some kind of In-House
corporate super villain locker room I've
got the metal bird wings oh yeah I've
got the metal tentacles
you guys are all lame I've got the Rhino
suit who was the mysterious cloaked
stranger in the Hat wandering the Earth
to tease both of these Bad sequel baits
I guess we'll never know technically
this isn't a post-credit scene since
that was reserved for the very confusing
X-Men Days of Future Past teaser but
it's following up on tasm one's teaser
as well and it's funny watching this in
retrospective knowing that Sony bungled
this attempt so badly that they needed
to finally get along with Disney again
to get Spider-Man projects off the
ground you know if you think about it no
way home was kind of a Sinister Six
movie
one two three four five
six he spawned too far away on the map
to participate before the match ended
better luck next time Venom well that
little bit of sentient sludge on a bar
top lead to anything or just be more
fodder for this list only time will tell
but Matt gargan says chances are slim
the hell's going on with that speaking
of random ominous villains showing up to
tease future movies one of my favorites
comes from the Shazam movies yes both of
them they both have basically the same
post-credits scene poor Mark Strong's Dr
Savannah is locked up drawing ancient
magic symbols along his prison cell
hoping to recreate the spells that got
him to the wizard shazam's Rock of
Eternity when he hears a chilling voice
coming from somewhere why it's uh a
caterpillar yeah this is Mr Mind an old
Captain Marvel villain don't make me
explain the Captain Marvel thing you're
smart you get it that's popped up every
now and again in big climactic events
throughout DC's comic book history so
seeing him standing there explaining his
plans for conquest and general evil
stuff General evil stuff was pretty dang
cool as obscure as Mr mind is and how
well the first shazam movie was received
you'd think we'd maybe get Savannah
teaming up with him in the sequel
instead we just got what appears to be
even the filmmakers realizing that scene
wasn't going to go anywhere and poke
even more fun at it by essentially
reproducing the scene almost shot for
shot even having Savannah get super
frustrated about how it's been two
goddamn years Mr Mind slinks away into
his hidey hole likely never to be seen
again what with the whole DC film reboot
and all I like to imagine he doesn't
even go anywhere to do anything he just
sits behind that little great nibbling
on a discarded piece of lettuce or
something that would be way funnier
after teaming up with the Fantastic Four
to battle all too embarrassed to
actually attempt Galactus Silver Surfer
lies in a deep Slumber in the far
reaches of space before his eyes open
and he shushes the audience to reattach
his decapitated head actually based on
the trajectory of that board it may have
sliced his head off why'd it fly up so
far a lot of these kind of look similar
because they didn't have the confidence
to fully commit to a major story beat
happening after the names rolled up
sometimes you can view them more as just
a way to assure the audience that not
every character died like a punk and
they'll live on even if the movies don't
show us as much but the plan for this
one was definitely a spin-off J Michael
last name of Spider-Man and Babylon 5
Fame actually wrote a script for this
Silver Surfer film that fox
unfortunately passed up this one's a
bummer because I thought radical rad was
the best part of this movie and the Dual
performance from Doug Jones and Lawrence
Fishburne really came together to make
him exactly how I imagined him looking
and sounding in the comics I'm surprised
with the amount of cosmic Marvel rep in
the MCU this guy hasn't come back yet in
any form I'm pretty burned out on MCU
stuff in general right now because it's
so many mid or poor quality projects
coming out all at once but if they said
they were going to do some Silver Surfer
and proper Galactus stuff I'd be seated
for sure another pretty dope DC bad guy
that didn't get his do is Deathstroke
AKA
yeah wow his name is really fun to say
dramatically who showed up in the
post-credits scene of 2017's theatrical
cut of Justice League he pulls up to the
yacht in a little motorboat then slo-mo
walks up the stairs like a badass and
then he stands there talking to Jesse
Eisenberg for a minute or so before
smirking and disappearing into our
hearts and Minds Deathstroke is such a
uniquely cool character that he seems to
work for me in every medium every actor
that plays him every variation of his
costume everything he's just cool he's
intimidating he's wicked with a weapon
he's simply awesome which makes it
doubly disappointing that this scene
actually sets up two different sequels
depending on which version you watch yes
Slade on a boat happens in both Justice
League and Zack Snyder's Justice League
but with different dialogue each time in
the theatrical Luthor brings up the idea
of crafting A League of Their Own both
referencing the Rosie O'Donnell baseball
movie and teasing the formation of the
Injustice League or gang or Society or
whatever they were going to go with if
they even had a go with planned in the
Snyder cut Luthor instead tells Slade
that Batman is really Bruce Wayne which
was a setup for Ben Affleck's canceled
version of the Batman recently we've
gotten word through those involved with
that project that it was going to be
pretty damn great and while I'm mostly
cool with everybody and everything
moving on boy would I love to see the
Batman from the warehouse fight go up
against a Snyder vs Deathstroke
it couldn't have been anything but
glorious but either way Slade V Batman
or Injustice Bros neither are gonna
happen and that's just a darn shame I
know this one's pretty unremarkable but
it's a funny excuse to talk about how
the X-Men franchise were seriously
planning to have Mr Sinister as a
villain in upcoming sequels what would
be your dream character to play villain
wise villain wise I'm there Mr Sinister
has always been some I'd love to see how
they handle his name either having every
character just staunchly refused to call
him anything other than Nathaniel Essex
or lampshading it by having a comic
relief character go oh wow that's your
name that's dumb given that they almost
backed out of calling the character
Victor Von Doom in the 2015 Fantastic
Four reboot I'm inclined to believe it's
the former this is another halfway one
where yes technically Wolverine's DNA
samples kept at Alkali Lakes facilities
did come into play later on just not
anything to do with Sinister the Essex
Corporation
at least we got Laura Kinney out of all
this weirdness I've been focusing mostly
on pretty recent movies but all the way
back in 1997 we got the infamous Arnold
Schwarzenegger George Clooney Chris
O'Donnell Batman and Robin Uma Thurman
Alicia Silverstone
oh is that not the full title my bad
while this movie didn't technically have
a post-credits scene it did still end on
a pretty sequel bait e moment where the
trio of Batman Robin and Batgirl are all
finally on good terms having just
defeated the bad guys and saved Alfred
and are ready to do a nice little go
team hand thing we're going to need a
bigger cave
the three of them are suddenly in their
costumes running in slow motion in front
of the bat signal towards the camera in
a shot mimicking the previous dynamic
duo only version from the previous movie
Batman Forever I actually really dig the
way these ended letting you the little
kiddo James viewer know that Batman and
Co will be back
they just gotta go run an errand real
quick and yet we never got the Batman
Unchained or Batman triumphant or
whatever it was going to be called Joel
Schumacher was removed from the
franchise after Batman and Robin tanked
pretty hard and the bat nipples were
hung up to wait for just the right
Christopher Nolan nearly a decade later
and hey I get it while the movie is so
bad it's good in many ways it's also
just plain bad hilarious but bad I get
why we didn't get another one but damn
if they didn't think they would
morbius as a whole was just an entirely
embarrassing situation between them
making this crap ass movie in the first
place and then the internet tricked Sony
into letting it bomb at the box office
not once but twice and you can see where
they had to reshoot the movie to
coincide with no way home based on the
trailers because the right hand wasn't
talking to the left my guess from the
trailers was that morbias and Adrian
tombs would team up to break out of the
prison together to form the middle Act
of the movie and solidify their bond for
a future crossover
then no way home and Venom 2 made it as
clear as possible that the Sony Universe
isn't the MCU they had to rethink the
parameters of the team up which they
couldn't back down from now because it
was already in the trailers we already
put so much potential Spider-Man
crossover in the marketing you gotta do
something so we're left with this
confusing but hilarious line of dialogue
I'm not sure how I got here has to do
with Spider-Man I think I'm still
figuring this place out but I think a
bunch of guys like us should team up for
no reason at all vulture and morbius are
now buds vulture just heard rumors about
a crazed vampire man and was like yeah
yeah that guy seems like someone I could
chill with let's do a meet-up the funny
thing is I think this actually
retroactively makes sense now Spider-Man
across the spider-verse showed that
because all of the Multiverse
Shenanigans in the recent movies
Spider-Man's Rogues Gallery was now
being randomly displaced to the wrong
World it needed to be returned by Miguel
O'Hara in his spider Society they even
had a vulture who got put in the wrong
World in that movie this sort of forms a
sensible picture now because of pure
luck I don't think this is all ever the
intention when they were developing
these but Sony managed to accidentally
back into a solution will this ever get
followed up
I would like to think no because morbius
was a giant flop but they could always
go the dumbest route possible with the
new Craven movie and have Rhino and
cravenov get added to these guys group
next stop trying to make Sinister Six
happen it's never gonna happen the last
one I want to really give a spotlight to
is Constantine yes it is pronounced that
way and yes I'm gonna be a stickler
about it now for the rest of my life I
don't care that they say Constantine in
this movie I don't care about this movie
but the studio sure thought people would
as the credits come to a close and we
open back up on a graveyard where our
lead hero is saying some last goodbyes
to Shia LaBeouf's character Chas who
spoilers died near the end of the movie
you know hang on I guess we could just
say this is Constantine because this is
basically a different character this was
all I knew of the guy when my
ex-girlfriend made me watch this movie
at her house in 2005 and then I promptly
forgot literally everything about it but
now that I've seen and read much better
things with Constantine this guy gets to
be Constantine it said build its Canon
it's all of the above anyway Chas La
buff is an angel now apparently does a
cool glowy eyes stance and then zooms
away into the clouds Shia was pretty
dang popular at the time what with Even
Stevens and holes and all that and would
go on to starring the likes of
Transformers Indiana Jones 4 and other
memorable 2000s movies presumably
Constantine would eventually face Chas
or whatever his Angel name would be in a
sequel movie but what do you know we
never got that I finally watched
Constantine again I guess like just now
and aside from the final act it holds up
pretty well it's not an awful movie
especially if you just ignore the title
and think of it as the guy from The
Matrix but he's fighting demons and
stuff instead but still
I don't care if we ever find out what
this scene was all about
and we likely never will
some honorable mentions of course go to
the few non-marvel and DC movies that
have attempted to use this marketing
gimmick unsuccessfully themselves like
the GI Joe Snake Eyes movie that was
trying so very very hard to be like an
MCU movie at every turn no matter how
much it meant butchering the character
we get a scene where Snake Eyes rival
Storm Shadow is recruited by Cobra on a
plane ride and then he awkwardly
announces his new name for sequel that
won't happen maybe he'll show up in a
Transformers movie sometime soon though
meanwhile Transformers oh God what did I
do last night ends with a teaser that
Unicron is inside the Earth's core like
that Ark in Transformers Prime which
means if he ever transformed from the
shape of a ball into a big robot man
mode it would kill everyone ever that'd
be some great fodder for Michael Bay
destruction porn but I don't think they
could ever walk that back short of using
time travel and in a way that kind of
did because the new Transformers
rebooted timeline shows us that Unicron
is not lying dormant in the earth and is
somewhere else in the Galaxy looking for
the little blue planet I want him to
fight ego The Living Planet in Galactus
and the Death Star all at once for a big
Celestial Throwdown the other ones we've
got on our honorable mentions list are
new Power Rangers and Ghostbusters
womans and I have seen neither of those
so you're gonna take a Googling Journey
with me here real quick looks like
2017's Mighty movie was gonna mean
morphin time for the Green Ranger in a
future installment and and then the
movie tanked because everything I've
ever read or seen about this was that it
was pretty much Power Rangers for people
who aren't fans of Power Rangers too
realistic and girl Busters has a
post-credits scene where Leslie Jones
alludes to them having to fight Zuul
next time so all this does is make me go
ah yeah what a better movie and I
haven't even seen this newer one I'm
pretty sure that even newer Ghostbusters
afterlife kind of retcons or tries to
forget the SNL female cast members
version ever happened but I also haven't
seen that Xavier why did you put me in
charge of explaining these ones I just
like seeing you squirm a little bit
talking about anything other than DC
stuff watching your Marvel Easter eggs
videos like watching a lifelong Trekkie
try to talk at length about Star Wars
lore so delightfully out of the comfort
zone and of course we'd be remiss not to
mention the one that started it all
Masters of the Universe the movie ends
with Skeletor giving us an equally
menacing and campy I will be back
that never came to fruition The Flash
kind of half ends with the tease of the
new Aquaman movie and half ends with a
horrific pit in your stomach that this
movie didn't actually reboot jack [__]
and there's no way to know how much of
it will affect the new James Gunn DCU
going forward but more of my thoughts on
that in my dceu timeline video that I'm
plugging again because you can't stop me
you're editing this aren't you damn it
uh wait if people are hearing this and
then you left it in yay subscribe to me
and only me okay back to the timeline
Minds for you data slave find me more
newspapers and cartoons but with all
that said and done you gotta love the
mixture of overconfidence and
underpreparedness that makes scenes like
this happen Studios pour hundreds of
millions of dollars into these projects
but they're always a Gamble and as much
as they try to make it seem like it's
all been planned out ahead of time
sometimes you know when they're just
trying to make it all up as they go
along and hoping everyone will just roll
with it sometimes you get scenes that
successfully prepare a storyline that'll
go the distance with multiple sequels
and new character reveals and sometimes
you have a character just walk in and go
yeah I'm a badass get ready to see more
of me and then you never see more of
them and it's just kind of sad and
amazing just goes to show you never know
which movies people gravitate towards
maybe it'll do really well or maybe
it'll be a video about Judge Dredd I
always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign